so join us in the super chat natalia's
going to be reading them out um but i
want to pull up this story about the
women's
soccer team are you guys familiar with
what just happened with the women's
soccer team you know i asked if women
and men are equal and i want to bring up
this topic right here they're already
nodding their head but here it goes the
u.s soccer federation and women's team
announce equal pay deal and say that
this is truly historic so here's the
story the u.s women's national soccer
team has reached a first of its kind
deal with the u.s soccer federation that
closes the gender wage gap and ensures
equal pay with the men's national team
under the agreements which run through
2028 u.s soccer will become the first
federation in the world in the world to
equalize fifa world cup prize money
awarded to the teams for participating
world cup so we're the first in the
world go usa the agreements also ensure
that players on the women's and men's
team we paid identical appearance fees
and gain bonuses as well as share an
equal portion of the profits u.s soccer
makes
from its broadcast partner and
sponsorship deals ladies you're getting
equal pay how does that feel pearl
um
i don't think that men and women should
be paid the same in sports because they
don't put on like they don't make as
much money
so i i play volleyball and basketball in
europe and it it's unfortunate because
there's really not a lot of opportunity
in women's sports but i don't know how
you can complain when men make more
money at those sports so if you're a
business and one business brings in more
money and one business brings in less
money of course you're going to pay the
business that make the players
for the business that makes more money
more it's just common sense like they're
not
you don't see
male only fans models complaining
because they don't make the same as
their female counterparts but ali equal
pay for equal work isn't this is this
it's not equal work because it's about
the revenue so it's about how much money
are you bringing in like who watches
women's basketball here i don't watch
anything yeah okay are you sports guy
huge sports guys right do you want
yourself
yeah okay and you watch men's basketball
right all the time i i'm a female
athlete i'm i'm probably top like one
percent in terms of talent and how far
i've like taken well i mean when you
come count like cause you're tall you're
six foot i'm six foot like i have the
opportunity to play pro next year not a
lot of people get get to do that right
and i can tell you that i even in
basketball which i play
i i don't want to watch women's
basketball why is that even though you
play it because they're not they're not
as good
and i mean that's not fun i i genuinely
my heart of soul like i'll probably turn
down that contract because it just isn't
enough money how much do you think the
contract will be the contract well i
could go to a terrible country like a
country where like no one lives it's
like this island in like iceland or
something and make like three four grand
a month not bad right free housing but
i'd be living like in the middle of
nowhere or i could go to germany and get
like 500 a thousand a month and i have
nothing yeah and i have friends that
were like top 20 in the ncaas like they
played on those teams for volleyball and
like
they they might make 70 which which is
decent but
when you think they're in the top like
half
0.25 percent skill wise that's like
nothing so is this um ali for you is
this equality for the sake of equality
did these women earn that
no i don't think they earned it this is
why i think feminism is a female
supremacy movement
i'm just keeping it honest so there are
just some horrible facts of life if you
choose to look at them as awful it can
also be a benefit to be physically a
woman that's my perspective on it but
the reality is is that men are
faster they're stronger they can make
faster plays on the field where when you
watch female sports they're sluggish
they just move slower that's my that's
my perspective on it so they basically
wind enough to convince somebody to pay
them the same as men even though they're
not turning the same profit and then
what's the trickle-down effects of this
what what's the next area where women
are going to demand equal pay that takes
a sharp turn into communism and
redistribution of wealth i think it's
dangerous well and and you don't know
what that's going to do to the business
as a whole if you're like you you you
own a business right and you know if
you're paying your employees too much
and you can't keep up like you're not
making enough money to pay them like
that hurts everybody so like why
instead of instead of whining about
equal pay why don't we work on putting
on a better show so you think coco do
you think you think that you the u.s
soccer federation doesn't have money so
that's why like they should not give
them to the women i think there's enough
money to go around then why then why
wouldn't they give it to them they're
giving it right now aren't they but
why do they have to want like you don't
okay so you can't accept you're not
going to accept an offer that you're not
worth
so if they didn't if they weren't cool
with getting paid that much they
shouldn't have accepted the initial
offer
and so like now now you're going to see
them like gassing up the price even
though i'm sure like the revenue
hasn't gone up go ahead do you think
they deserve this oh good for them okay
well it doesn't hurt me yeah let me let
me just i'm not a huge soccer fan but i
can tell you this i watched like male
soccer in europe yeah the the uh let me
just tell me if this changes your guys
perspective at all
the u.s
women's soccer team what are they doing
in that picture
they win a championship they won they're
actually winners right the men's team
freaking sucks sorry male soccer team so
because they won should they get paid
more well
or is it just revenue the bottom line
yeah it should be based on like i don't
know the numbers behind right so if this
was a situation where they really were
bringing in more money and they're
demanding a raise fine fine but what
happens more often than not even if it's
a losing men's team they tend to make
more than a woman's team
and i'm a female athlete i spent most of
my life playing sports like i really
care about women's sports but i can't
whine and cry because more people
attended the men's basketball games in
college than ours like it just is what
it is and we can either work to improve
the sport as a whole or we can whine
about our pay and i'm just tired of
these girls whining about their pay
instead of like focus on your sport get
better
go ahead you know they got beat by a
high school uh high school soccer team
the men's the women's team got beat by a
men's soccer team yes men's high school
yes that's i that's actually something
that occurred so they're gonna get this
equal pay with these male athletes that
are you know top tier but they can't
even compete with high schoolers
so like i don't think they earned it
so
you're bringing up valid points here
i do you ever like i assume you're going
to start running into women that are
going to start yelling at you pretty
soon i don't think she cares about that
at all
we already do
really
what are those interactions like go to
the dirtiest dirtiest weirdest most
salacious comment what do you get i had
someone tell me that they were going to
do witchcraft on me and my future babies
so that was a lot who was that person i
don't need her name but like why did she
say this what is she about i don't know
i think she got triggered by me tick
tock i mean whoever reads the comment
into every video is gonna have some like
if you post a puppy video somebody's
gonna say look at this [ __ ] that [ __ ]
this woman was special this woman was
special she was like calling me on
instagram and like trying to get her
girlfriend to call me too but obviously
these are low value women that coco
doesn't associate with you know what i
mean so yeah the weirdest thing out
there i think i had somebody send a
letter to my school once too a letter to
your school i didn't even know that yeah
somebody googled my school and sent me a
letter i mean it was a creep though
i was i was in college i just graduated